okay what up guys welcome to the just
Hurley things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning uh water thoughts
because I don't have coffee it's
actually not even the morning but you
know
you know mind your business mind your
business anyways um today I want to talk
about like
something that someone said to me the
other day that kind of bothered me
I don't want to say bothered me because
he didn't mean anything by it but it
kind of rubbed me the wrong way and
someone said to me wow you're such an
overnight success
oh
um I don't want to talk about how I feel
like my whole life I've been preparing
for this
but I didn't know what I Was preparing
for exactly but I always knew that I was
gonna be in like the public platform or
in the public eye in some capacity
someday so
um let's start so
when I was in college I was always
really curious and I would say that's
like the number one thing that I am is
I'm very nosy
and I'm very curious that always I'm
like thinking of like why do we believe
what we believe and like what's right
what's wrong and I'm always just like
looking for an answer
and so when I was in college I was very
confused because I'm a very empathetic
person
so some of the left like leaning ideas
kind of like felt good to me
um and I I also had a lot of guilt
growing up for growing up with like
um a wealthy family like I felt like I
was so like privileged and all of that
you know I just I felt like guilty about
it that you know my Dad paid for my
college and you know my dad was always
willing to help me and all that like
just made me feel very very guilty
um I don't know why you know it doesn't
really make sense but
so at the time like I emphasize I don't
want to say I was super left I didn't
vote um in the first election I could
have voted for which is Trump versus
Hillary because I just didn't know and I
didn't feel like one way or the other so
I
um
yeah I was just like confused so in that
time I started my my senior year of
college I started super senior year I
started reading books oh I I graduated
in four years just to clarify I did a
year of like a market research
certification so it wasn't yeah okay
anyways I didn't fail that's what I'm
saying
um
so I started reading like Thomas Sowell
and listening to like all these
different like
um conservative and left like speakers
at the time like I used to re listen to
um
I can't remember their name but that
the big like Hispanic guy and like that
white lady I don't know they have like
this news thing that I would listen to
too but I would listen to both sides and
I would read on both sides and the
conservative ideas just like made more
sense with what I had seen in the world
like I grew up in a very like
um diverse background not not from where
where I grew up wasn't diverse
necessarily but like my dad always went
to India um I grew up with German
nannies South African nannies like I
grew up with nannies from all over the
world I grew up um
so
I didn't see the world as like this
negative place where there's no
opportunity if you're a woman or if
you're a minority or whatever because I
just grew up like my dad hired Indians
all of his best employees were from
India
um and
that that sort of thing so um
in college I I would read all these
books and I really wanted to know like
why I believed what I believed and um I
ended up taking a sales job
and when I was in sales like
I
started
to like view the world as just this like
land of opportunity and I felt like I
could get on the phone with anybody and
I wasn't really good at selling closing
wasn't my strong suit but I was like a
top G when it came to getting on the
phone with like top Executives like I I
would get hung up on I didn't have the
best pitch but I could get on the phone
with Eddie oh my God anyone and another
way that I thought of back then was like
I decided I wanted to know like top
Executives at these companies in
Milwaukee and I was trying to like build
a network and I just decided to call up
top Executives and see if they would
meet with me and like give me life
advice
and mind you this is before I even had a
YouTube channel I just I'm nosy and I
like talking to people that like know
things and I don't know so
um
yeah so I ended up meeting with like the
CFO uh We Energies if you know what that
is and the CIO of um Harley-Davidson so
two like billion dollar companies these
Executives just like met with me and I
like asked them about their life how
they were successful all this stuff
really cool it was and that kind of like
opened my eyes
to just how much opportunity there is in
the world like I I genuinely believe
that I can do anything if I put my mind
to it and I believe most people if you
are you know I mean
some people just are really you're not
that smart but like I I don't view
myself as smart like when I did the acts
I got a slightly above average score but
it was nothing crazy
um but I truly believe that if you work
hard and you are creative and you really
put your mind something like you can do
anything and so next
I decided like randomly one day I was
just gonna quit my job and move home
um and my plan was to go to England in
like three months and stay home start
building like a YouTube channel and Tick
Tock Channel
um but
my my season got canceled because of
covid so I was stuck at home for like a
year
and maybe like three months roughly a
year and three months and
um
yeah so um I was jobless and I decided
that I was just going to be a tick
tocker and a YouTuber and it was tick
tocker at the time but then now it's a
YouTuber but my mom was horrified my dad
was horrified
um they thought I was insane and I was
but
um
they
my parents my dad has always told me
like do what you love
and
I loved making videos I just loved it
like I love telling a cool story I like
like putting the punch line in I like
I've just been I feel like I'm a natural
born Entertainer and my dad
um even though he thought it was nuts he
he encouraged me and every day I would
wake up and I would make I swear to God
like 10 videos a day
um and it was the same thing when I
started my YouTube channel like there
were days where I did 10 15 reactions
like back to back to back to back and
people will call me an overnight success
um but I'm like how many of you have put
out
hundreds of videos in a week
hundreds
nobody no and that's the thing like you
can't find
that post as much as I did and used to
post this like as much as I did back
then when I was coming up and
I'm sure there's one but not many and
that's the thing like people will be
like wow this is overnight but I I
posted for
a year and a half two years roughly I
don't know when I started but
no breaks
um
constantly
at least five times a day across
platforms and
um
had really no luck like I really didn't
make much money
um not I mean I definitely made less
than I made in my sales job like by a
lot
and it was an ego hit like
I was like the loser of my family like
all of my siblings are Ultra successful
they're all like my brother's an
engineer my sister's a property manager
and she like manages this whole area
like every like hard work and success in
my family is just like expected and I I
genuinely felt like such a loser at home
because I'm like unemployed I'm trying
to do this job that no one seems to be
able to do and it really like it hits
your ego and I can't even imagine it's
probably worse as a man because as a
woman like the end you know
Society kind of expects expects that a
little bit but as a man like you move
home and be with your parents to start a
business like people kind of look at you
funny but the thing is like in order to
achieve what you want to achieve like
you have to be willing to put aside your
ego and most people aren't willing to do
that they don't want to quit the job
like who cares quit your job you can get
a new job
you can and I'll tell you okay so one
YouTube video you could look this back
this is one of the first YouTube videos
I put on my channel it was me going
door-to-door in rich neighborhoods and
asking for work and I I didn't want a
job
I just wanted to see if I could get one
and literally I did that one day and I
got the CEO of other company their
recruiter like called me because I
knocked on his door and that's my thing
like you just never know who's on the
other side of stuff like
just from being curious and like asking
about people like
um my manager works at like a big media
you just quit his job shout out me
um
um but he worked at a quit a big Media
company and I I literally had a cold
LinkedIn message to him and said hey I'm
looking to get into YouTube and I just
had like some questions about it and he
kind of ignored me for a year and then
after a year like he finally said yes
and then
um
yeah and then he ended up like seeing
talent in me and managing me and it's
like all of these pieces wouldn't have
happened
if I wasn't posting 10 times a day if I
wasn't
chasing after opportunity like it was my
job like
I I just see people
that like are around me and know me and
I I they want to do what I'm doing but
I'm baffled that like when I meet
someone that knows something I don't I'm
asking a million questions I'm asking
like how did you do this what what do
you recommend for that like what would
you how would you write that like and
it's like how are you gonna make
something happen if you're not taking
the most out of every opportunity like
thank you
I I bought sessions with the roommates
with two like two Uh Kevin Samuels I
bought like just because I was asking
like you want to talk to people that
know what they're doing
and even now like who posts more than I
do I think I posted 20 times yesterday
and so a lot of times like people see me
and they're like oh you got this many
subscribers in this many months but I'm
like yeah but for two years I I probably
posted more than you did in five
I I probably like
in two years I guarantee I posted more
than most YouTubers do in five even
before I hired anybody to help post for
me
um
so my biggest advice to people that want
to grow on YouTube
and who knows maybe this end's in six
months I don't know but
is literally like
you don't know how much time you have
left on this planet and you don't know
when you're going to start a family and
you just never know you never know and
so I live life like I am running out of
time and if I don't accomplish and like
do the things that I want to do
um
like it'll never happen because I think
the biggest thing is people will always
wait till tomorrow they're always going
to say I'll take the risk tomorrow I'll
do it tomorrow like you have to have
that mentality of like you will figure
it out
I was almost out of money in March and
I'm like you know what I'll figure it
out like what's what's the worst that
could happen you quit your job to follow
your dreams what is the worst that could
happen you have to find a new job you
get you waitress part-time like who
cares because you don't know when like
let's say I started doing red pill stuff
what if I waited what if I waited two
years like it wouldn't be as hot as it
is now so you just never know when it's
your time and you never know when it's
your turn and you will miss
opportunities because you're not doing
it now so that's that's my advice it's
literally like if you have a dream and
you have a passion and you genuinely
like believe that you can do what
someone else is doing and you can do it
better because you have to know yourself
too are you an Entertainer are you not
an Entertainer like
I don't know it depends what your dream
is but like literally
act like you have
x amount of years to do it
and it might not work and what's the
worst that could happen if it doesn't
work at least you can say you put
everything into it but I don't know
that's my advice
I think I talked in circles a little bit
but that's that's the mentality that
keeps me on YouTube so and how I got
here I feel like it was years of work
really but let me know in the comments
if you have any other questions
um like the video don't forget to
subscribe I'll talk to you next time